Welcome everybody to another Zoom call.
We're ready to get started.
Revived your again if there's announcements.
You'll see it on the members only site, the homepage.
Let's jump in with your questions.
If you have questions, feel free to chat them in a long way.
First question.
What are the main reasons someone would use DMSO?
So DMSO is diamethyl sulfoxide.
It became very popular back in the 1970s, 80s.
As a strong anti-inflammatory agent for joint inflammation.
People with band-dies, band-shoulders and things.
It's a liquid like a water.
People have taken it orally for inflammation.
And then it kind of fell out of sort.
I've got band-mouthed by that medical association,
the medical establishment, and slowly kind of fell out of sort.
But it is a very strong anti-inflammatory product.
You can buy it on Amazon now again.
You could, it is a driving agent.
So you have to do it to be careful with using it topically.
And if you had, let's say, a lotion on your skin or dirty skin.
Or a solvent like gasoline or something like that on your skin.
You put DMSO over it with literally really drive that into your bloodstream.
So you want to have clean skin if you're going to use it topically.
Or you're using it topically as a driving agent
to let's say drive an essential oil or something into your body.
But you have to be careful with that because an essential oil can be toxic at high doses.
So you do have to be careful using it in that sense.
I know there are some cancer protocols that use DMSO orally,
but they're using fairly low doses.
I would be cautious about doing that.
We have used DMSO topically with zinc to drive zinc into the tissues.
Zinc deficiency can be common with certain cancers.
Copper toxicity is common across the board, which is with cancer.
But copper and zinc kind of compete with each other.
There's a balance between copper and zinc in the tissues.
And when people have a zinc deficiency, you can build up too much copper.
And copper can be a driver of cancer because it could be a driver of growth.
And then you could end up with a copper toxicity issues.
Especially when people have gotten into Instagram fans of using copper,
you know, in their cooking and thinking that, you know,
more copper is better for you, which copper is an element of the periodic table.
It can function like a heavy metal.
It's typically considered more of a mineral, but it's needed in certain metabolic processes of the body,
but it's needed in very low doses.
So when you're taking elemental copper,
as some of these Instagrammers are pushing,
you could easily end up with copper toxicity.
And if you remember your genetics, there are copper transport genes,
and there's copper detoxifying genes.
And some people are going to have defects in that,
and they're going to be more prone to copper toxicity issues that don't get rid of copper very well.
So it can end up acting like a heavy metal toxicity in their body.
Zinc can tend to push that out.
So zinc, you know, that copper zinc ratio is good to measure with cancer patients,
because many cancers, for instance,
one known cancer is prostate cancer,
could have excess copper issues and have zinc deficiencies.
So taking zinc orally is one way to help combat that.
But sometimes, you know, to absorb your nutrients very well for all sorts of other reasons,
inflammation of the gut, et cetera.
So using a DMSO with a zinc to drive zinc into the tissues,
especially if you want to drive it into a specific area, can be beneficial.
So those would be the main reasons why someone would use DMSO.
Next question.
Is it good or bad to take iodine for cancer?
You know, I know there's a book written probably 40 years ago about using iodine for breast cancer.
I don't know if it was Dr. Brownsteed or somebody else who wrote that book.
And back probably in the 70s and 80s, maybe 60, 70s and 80s,
nutritional therapists, counterpractors, naturopaths,
nutritional people today, a lot of Instagramers and TikTok people,
what do you call those people, influencers, push iodine heavily.
New research has come out, and it's not even new research.
It's maybe 20 years old.
That has showed that excess iodine can be quite harmful for your thyroid gland.
Iodine is extremely attractive to your thyroid.
Your thyroid needs iodine, part of the T3 and T4 hormone that your thyroid makes
contains iodine, so iodine is necessary nutrient for your thyroid.
However, most people will get enough iodine in their diet to supplement everything and more than what your thyroid needs.
Now years and years ago, there used to be what's called the goiter belt.
That was the Midwest area, because in the Midwest, in the soil, we tend to have less iodine.
So people who don't have enough iodine, have an iodine deficiency, can be more prone to goiters.
That was the data at the time.
So they needed iodine.
So they started adding potassium iodine to salt, because everybody eats salt.
So you could remember, my insult, nobody buys this salt anymore, do you?
You're buying pig salt, you're buying good real salt, but the used to buy salt that was iodized salt.
And that's where you would get your iodine to supplement for the needs of the thyroid gland.
Well, that has kind of been debunked, besides the fact that nobody is just only eating your vegetables from your homegrown garden that the soil is deficient to iodine anymore.
You're getting food from all different sources that's coming from all across the country and out of our country.
So there's very few people that are deficient in iodine.
Now you could measure that in a blood test to see if you have iodine deficiency, and then you would be careful taking the amount that you would take.
But a lot of the dishes still hold to the old theory that everybody should be taking iodine, so they're taking iodine.
The problem is, is because iodine is so attractive to the thyroid gland, it can cause Hashimoto's really easy, which is an autoimmune thyroid.
So you do have to be careful with iodine.
I would not necessarily go and just jump in and everybody take iodine.
You could measure that to see if you have a deficiency.
And the skin topical ways of measuring, maybe you put liquid iodine on your skin in time, how long it takes for you to absorb it or not accurate.
I would not rely on that.
Get a blood test for a measuring iodine, if you think you have a deficiency in iodine.
We just have to see deficiencies in iodine when you measure them.
So again, it's better to measure, it's better to quantify before you just follow an influencer.
So bottom line is a good or bad to take iodine for cancer.
Well, at first of all, I don't think it solves anything for cancer.
But it's bad to take iodine because excess iodine can cause Hashimoto's.
You have to be careful with that.
Next question, does the right machine kill cancer directly or does it just stimulate the immune system to help your body kill cancer?
Well, that's a matter of debate.
Personally, I think it kills cancer directly.
Royal right believed it killed cancer directly.
I think anything that you hit with its own frequency is going to cause that thing to vibrate.
Whether it's light frequency or sound frequency, that would happen.
That's why you could take two to the 2D forks of the same frequency.
It's a take a 528 2D pork.
And it is not vibrating.
Take another one, hit it, vibrate it, put it near the other 2D pork without even touching it.
And you'll cause the other 2D pork.
There wasn't vibrating to vibrate.
Anything you hit with its own frequency will vibrate.
Now that itself, that itself can kill cancer cells.
Cancer cells are already highly oxidatively stressed.
They're already at the verge of death.
And they're continuing to replicate.
That's why all nutritional cancer therapies are stimulating a greater oxidative stress alternative cancer therapies.
As well as standards of care, cancer therapies, chemotherapy is causing a greater oxidative stress.
That's why it's killing cancer.
The right machine doesn't cause oxidative stress, but it causes that vibration.
In a sense, it can physically destroy the cancer.
In the second sense, it will help physically break down the waste layer that surrounds a growing highly metabolic cell structure.
That can hinder your immune system's ability to get at it.
And in a sense, when you bring frequency back to a cell, you can stop it from replicating.
So the right works in multiple different areas.
There's probably about 20 different theories on how the right works with cancer.
So those, I think, are the main ones that I just commented.
Does it stimulate the immune system to help kill the cancer?
Well, it aids the immune system to help kill the cancer, but I do think it helps kill the cancer directly.
And I don't think one can really argue with that when you see, I mean, people have argued,
oh, I just think that's antidotal evidence of your damnity research that shows that well, there is research coming out that vibration that frequencies do pill pathogens.
And there you can't argue with, you know, some people have said, well, it's just placebo medicine.
People just think it's going to work. That's why it works.
First of all, if that was the case, I don't care if I think something's going to work and it works.
All I care is that something worked.
Secondly, when people have used it on their animals, I don't think there's any placebo evidence going on that you can cat your cat can say,
oh, kitty, come here. We're going to do this on for your kidney cancer.
The event said you only have a few weeks to live, but we're going to run the kidney cancer frequency on you and see how you work.
And the cat believes you and gets better from their kidney cancer.
That's just nonsense. So when we have dozens and dozens of antidotal evidence that it works on children or animals that don't have a conscious placebo effect going on, you can't argue with its efficacy.
So there's probably other reasons on how frequencies work to help kill cancer and kill pathogens that we have yet to discover.
Unfortunately, you're not going to get these huge research studies behind it because those cost millions of dollars and nobody's funding those things.
Secondly, even if you could get some rich person to fund a study like that, you won't get it passed. You have to get a legal research study.
It has to go through the department of health to get qualifications to get these different NRB numbers and all this stuff to do in research study and they'll never pass something like that.
So maybe out of our country, you could get a research study. Then again, people will just pull through the research study. It's just making a difference.
So again, I'd be more interested that it just works for people and that's all I care.
Instead of trying to get funding to prove it to a population that is dog radically positioned against anything other than what makes them money.
So all I care is that it works.
Next question.
I've heard that recent studies have shown that radiation therapy for cancer could actually make things worse. Is this true?
It is true. There have been recent studies that show that doing radiation therapy for cancer, and it's typically, I think the studies were typically on soft tissue.
This is what there's been. It's not just recent studies. There's been studies over time that show that radiation and soft tissue can actually make things worse.
So that's why I've never been a fan of radiation unless it's a last ditch effort that the cancer's growing too fast.
Because if you, I know one of the, it never used to be this way, but about, I don't know, maybe it was five, eight years ago.
The recommendations from a college is to breast cancer patients. Now is that we have breast cancer.
We need to do a mastectomy or a lumpectomy, and then we need to do radiation and we need to do chemotherapy.
Or you do chemotherapy first to shrink the lump, and then do a lumpectomy or a mastectomy, and then do radiation.
And then typically if it's PR or you are positive, you use an astrosol or some other aromatase inhibitor.
To me, that's just nonsense. If you're going to, oh, radiate the area because there could be leftover cancer cells. Well, radiation itself is a major cause of cancer.
So you're not radiating a specific site. You're not meeting that site that is known to be cancerous.
If you could pinpoint radiation and just hit this certain one centimeter site, that would be great, but radiation doesn't have a stop point.
So it's going to go through whatever tissue it took to get to that one centimeter site.
And then through this one centimeter site, and then through the back of the person has an exit wound.
So you're going to be doing just as much damage on the entrance wound and the exit wound as you did on the site itself.
Well, we're going to target it in different rays. So it's going to go at different angles so that you're going to have less radiation at each individual entrance wound and each individual exit road.
So that you're not going to just destroy tissue at that site. Yeah, but you're damaging the tissue enough to cause enough oxidative stress that could cause cancer and any of those given sites.
So I'm not a big fan of that. So yes, recent studies and old studies have shown that radiation therapy, it's known that cause cancer.
It certainly can make things worse. So I would say yes, that is true to them.
Next question. If my oncologist is insisting on chemotherapy and seems to go against everything I suggest, what should I do?
Well, I would find a different oncologist. You know, it's still a free world and we still live in a free health free world health care system.
You don't have to stay with who you were initially signed a sign. So you can even in their old system, let's say you were going to Minnesota oncology or you're going to Mayo.
And you don't like your oncologist, you know, just feel like nothing is your suggestions are not being heard. Your desires are not being heard.
You feel like they just don't really care or you feel like they just, you know, are pushing their agenda, whatever it is, you know, if you don't like me, you don't have to stay with me.
You don't like your oncologists go to someone else. There's nothing wrong with that. You don't, you're not here to please. Some people are such people pleasers, you're afraid you're going to hurt somebody's feelings.
And then you put your life at risk. So don't be foolish. You know, there's lots of oncologists that will take you, especially if you go to them and say, hey, I was at Mayo.
And they were just pushing their agenda. I really want to find somebody that I can work with the next person you talked to will probably be somebody with I would never do that. Oh, no, we can work with you, even though they might have done that to somebody else, you know, two visits before that.
So just raise your concerns, you know, and you know, again, like anything, I don't think you should be dogmatically positioned either way. I think the best thing is to with a lot of prayer and supplication, bring your request may known to God.
And he will direct your paths and he will give you a piece that passes all understanding. If you don't have peace about doing a certain therapy, then you shouldn't do that therapy.
You above all things you want to be obedient to what God is leading you to do. Not doing something to please someone else or doing something to do a piece of system.
And that includes not just your, your oncologist includes family members. You have to stand up for what God is telling you to do years ago. I had a patient that came to me, pancreatic cancer, late stage, just diagnosed.
He was doing really well with alternative therapy about just about a month into care. That's who we saw a lot. We had did a lot of therapies in the office at the time.
He was coming in every day to do the therapies. He was looking better. His blood work was looking better. And his son was just very upset that he was not doing chemotherapy.
It was just, it was just distraught that he was not going to do his dad was not going to keep a therapy. He thought his dad was going to die.
If you didn't do chemotherapy, it was just literally having panic attacks. And that's what caused the dad to cave. It's that I'm going to go, I just don't think I should do this.
But I got to go ahead and do it because I just really care. Obviously for my son, he did chemotherapy. He died in just a couple of weeks. I'm convinced of the chemotherapy.
He wasn't his cancer was not progressing. The chemotherapy for pancreatic cancer is very severe. And that's one of the main reasons I believe that that pancreatic cancer patients tend not to survive.
Do not do things just because someone else is pressure and you do that no matter if somebody you love or somebody you don't know.
It's you do things in anything in life, whether it's making a decision about your health care or making a decision about your job, you should be doing things because you're consulting by the power of the Holy Spirit, your Heavenly Father.
And being obedient to God is foremost in having a relationship with God.
My children will hear my voice. It says, Jesus said, and we need to be listening to it in much prayer in all our big life decisions.
We don't need to spiritualize whether we should buy butter or the store or something else, but we make it big life decisions. These are the things that we are to take to the Lord.
And he desires to for us to depend on him for those things.
Okay, next question. I know that I'm supposed to, that I'm not supposed to be eating dairy, but can I have a pizza once in a while?
So remember that your diet is a diet. It's not a religion. So can you cheat on your diet once in a while? Yes, you can.
Okay, you know, I think that, you know, I think your body can handle it once in a while. So yes, so don't be so hard on yourself that you take every joy out of your life either.
So just keep that in mind. It's a diet to help your body heal. The more healthy you get, the more, you know, often you can cheat and feel good about it and feel like you're still able to bounce back and get back on track.
Okay, any other questions? Those were all the questions that came in today. So we're going to have a shorter meeting here if you guys don't think of something.
Okay, well, thank you for being on it today. Remember we're back every Wednesday. So think of something after we hang up here, feel free to get it in the questions.
So we'll get to it next Wednesday and God bless and have a great afternoon.